I'd like to tell you today about an orca
named Tahlequah Tahlequah is also known
as j35 to scientists because she swims
with the j-pod and the Salish Sea these
are the waters off of British Columbia
in Washington State
now last year in July 2018 she was well
along in her 17 month pregnancy and
scientists were very excited because no
baby had survived in this pod for three
long years now orcas are also known as
killer whales they're profoundly social
and profoundly intelligent beings and
scientists are very interested in their
behavior because in their social
networks they share habits information
and even affection they create true
cultures of the ocean but this pod has
been in trouble the Chinook salmon that
the orcas favored has been way down in
the region and pollution has been up but
on July 24th Tahlequah gave birth to a
daughter and scientists were so excited
by this development but unfortunately
the same day in fact shortly after birth
the calf died well what happened next
electrified animal lovers across the
world because Tahlequah refused to let
her babies slip off into the water she
kept it on her body and she swam with it
if it did fall off she would dive and
rescue it and she battled stiff currents
to do this now she kept this behavior up
for 17 days and during this time she
swam over a thousand miles at that point
she left a little baby slip off into the
water
so today Tahlequah swims on with the
j-pod but her grief still moves me and I
do believe that
Karif is the right word to use I believe
that grief is the right word to use for
numerous animals who mourn the dead they
may be friends or mates or relatives
because these visible cues these
behavioral cues tell us something about
an animal's emotional state now for the
last seven years I've been working to
document examples of animal grief in
birds in mammals and domesticated
animals and in wild animals and I
believe in the reality of animal grief
now I say it this way because I need to
acknowledge to you right up front that
not all scientists agree with me and
part of the reason I think it's because
of what I call the a word the a where it
is anthropomorphism and historically
it's been a big deterrent to recognizing
animal emotions so anthropomorphism is
when we project onto other animals our
capacities or our emotions and we can
all probably think of examples of this
let's say we have a friend who tells us
my cat understands everything I say or
my dog she's so sweet he ran right
across the yard this morning towards a
squirrel and I know he just wants to
play well maybe or maybe not
I'm skeptical about claims like those
but animal reef is different because
we're not trying to read an animal's
mind we're looking at visible cues of
behavior and trying to interpret them
with some meaning now it's true
scientists often push back at me and
they'll say ah look the animal might be
stressed or maybe the animals just
confused because his or her routine has
been disrupted but I think that this
over worried about anthropomorphism
misses a fundamental point and that is
that animals can care very deeply for
each other maybe they even love each
other and when they do a survivors heart
can be pierced by a death let's face it
if we deny evolutionary continuity we
are really missing out on embracing part
of ourselves so yes I believe in the
reality of atom
grief and I also think that if we
recognize it we can make the world a
better place for animals a kinder place
for animals so let me tell you a little
bit more about animal grief I'm going to
start in Kenya and you see here there's
an elephant named Eleanor who came one
day with bruised legs and she collapsed
you see on the left that another female
named grace came to her right away and
using her own trunk propped her up tried
to get her up on her feet and she did
succeed but then Eleanor collapsed again
at this point grace became visibly
distressed and she prodded the body and
she vocalized Eleanor collapsed again
and unfortunately she did die what you
see on the right is a female from
another family named Maui who came after
the death and she stayed at the body she
held a vigil there and she even rocked
in distress over the body so the
scientists watching the elephants kept a
close observation on Eleanor's body for
seven days and during those seven days a
parade of elephants came from five
different families now some were just
curious but others carried out behaviors
that I really believe should be
classified as grief so what does grief
look like it can be rocking as I said in
distress
it can also be social withdrawal when an
animal just takes himself or herself
away from friends and stays by
themselves or failure to eat or sleep
properly sometimes a depressed posture
or vocalization it can be very helpful
for those of us studying this to be able
to compare the behavior of a survivor
before death and after death because
that increases the rigor of our
interpretation and I can explain this to
you by talking about two ducks named
Harper and Cole so we're in two birds
now so Harper and Cole were raised at a
foie gras factory and they were treated
cruelly when foie gras does involve
forced feeding of birds
this hurt their bodies and their spirits
were not in good shape either but
thankfully they were rescued by Farm
Sanctuary in upstate New York and for
four years they stabilized and they were
fast friends they often took themselves
to a small pond on the property then
coal started to have really intractable
pain in his legs and it was clear to the
sanctuary that he had to be euthanized
humanely and he was but then in the
sanctuary workers did a brilliant thing
because they brought Harper to the body
to see and at first Harper prodded the
body of his friend but then he laid
himself over it and he stayed there for
over an hour with his friend and in the
weeks after he had a hard time he would
go back to that same pond where he had
been with coal and he didn't want any
other friends and within two months he
died as well now I'm happy to say that
not all grieving animals have this
sorrowful outcome last summer I flew to
Boston to visit my adult daughter Sarah
I was with my husband Charlie I really
needed a break from work but I succumbed
and I checked my work email you know how
that is and there was a communication
about a dejected donkey now as an
anthropologist this wasn't what I
expected but there it was and I'm glad I
read it because a donkey named Lena had
gone to another Farm Sanctuary this one
in Alberta Canada as the only donkey
there and had trouble making friends for
that reason but she eventually did make
friends with an older horse named Jake
and for three years they were
inseparable but the reason the email
came was that Jake at age 32 the horse
had become gravely ill and had to be put
down and this is what was going on this
is Lena standing on Jake's grave she
didn't want to come in at night she
didn't want to come in for food she
didn't want to come in for water she
pawed at the grave she braids in
distress and there she stood so we
talked and we brainstormed what do you
do for an animal like that
and we talked about the role of time of
extra love and kindness from people and
of urging her to make a new friend and
here's where her trajectory does diverge
from that of Harper the duck because she
did make a new friend and sanctuary
workers wrote back and said it worked
out well
now sometimes scientists supplement
observation with hormonal analysis
there's an example of a group of
scientists in Botswana who took fecal
material from baboons and compared to
different groups the first group were
females who had witnessed a predator
attack and lost someone in that attack
and the second group were females who
had witnessed an attack but had not lost
someone and the stress hormones were way
up in that first group but here's the
thing the scientists didn't just call
them stressed baboons they called them
bereaved baboons and in part that's
because of the observations that they
made for example this mother-daughter
pair were very close and then the
daughter was killed by a lion
the mother removed herself from all her
friends from her grooming networks and
just stayed by herself for weeks
bereavement and she then slowly
recovered so we have bereaved baboons
well science tell us some day about
bereaved bees will we hear about frogs
who mourn I don't think so and I think
the reason is because animals really
need one-to-one close relationships for
that to happen I also know that
circumstance matters and personality
matters I have documented cats and dogs
who grieve are companion animals but I
also interacted with a woman who was
extremely bothered because her dog
wasn't grieving she said to me the first
dog in the house has died the second
animal does not seem concerned the
second dog what is wrong with him and if
I listened to her I realized that this
dog was now the only animal in the
household and as far as he was concerned
that was a pretty good deal so
circumstances matter now in
animals are not going to grieve exactly
like we do we have human creativity we
paint our grief dance our grief right
our grief we also can grieve for people
we've never met across space and time I
felt this strongly when I went to Berlin
and I stood at the Holocaust memorial
animals don't grieve exactly like we do
but this doesn't mean that their grief
isn't real it is real and it's searing
and we can see it if we choose now I've
lost both my parents I lost a very dear
friend at a young age from AIDS I
believe most likely most of you here
have lost someone and I have found it a
genuine comfort a solace to know that we
aren't the only beings on this earth who
feel love and grief and I think this is
important I also think we can take this
a step further and we can realize that
the reality of animal grief can help us
be better and do better for animals this
is already happening with Tahlequah
because the united states and canada
have renewed their talks with greater
urgency for how to help the Orcas how to
restore the chinook salmon and how to
help with the water pollution we could
also see that if grief is real there's
tremendous plausibility to the notion
that animals feel a whole range of
things so we could look at joy sadness
even hope and if we do that here's how
we can start to think about the world we
can look at orcas and say we know they
grieve we know they feel their lives and
we can refuse to confine them to small
tanks in theme parks and make them
perform for our entertainment we can
we can look at elephants and say yes
they grieve and we can renew our efforts
against international trophy hunting and
against poaching and we can look at our
closest living relatives monkeys and
apes and know yes they grieve they feel
their lives so they don't deserve to be
confined in a highly invasive biomedical
experiments year after year and you know
the Ducks Harper and Cole they tell us
something too they help us connect the
dots and realize that what we eat
affects how animals live and it's not
just foie gras and it's not just ducks
we can think about pigs and chickens and
cows in factory farms and we can know I
can tell you the science is real but
these animals feel too so every single
time we choose a plant-based meal we are
contributing to reducing animal
suffering so yes I believe in the
reality of animal grief I believe in the
reality of animal love and I think it is
time for us humans to recognize that we
don't own these things and when we see
that we have an opportunity to make the
world so much better for animals a
kinder world a gentler world and along
the way we might just save ourselves -
thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]